- Ever since I was a child
I've been depressed.
And my mother used to always tell me
that I stress out like a grown man.
It's always been a problem for me.
I let a lot of people get away with things
and take advantage of me,
do all kinds of things to where
I just let it go,
because I don't wanna deal with the drama.
And this is the result
of saying, you're not gonna take anymore.
I had a disagreement with somebody.
I'm not gonna say who they are
or what they do,
but
this person is very disrespectful.
Name calling for no apparent reason
and just disrespectful.
An evil ass lady, woman.
She's evil.
Disrespectful ass bitch.
And I finally had enough.
And because I finally had enough
and I took action,
this is the result.
You know, it could have been a lot worse,
but because I chose not to
defend myself.
Yes, it's a female,
but I didn't get into a fight
with the female.
It was someone else.
He's uh.
He sucker-punched me.
Okay.
Long story short,
I didn't see it coming.
And he hit me directly
in my eyeball.
And that's why it is the way it is now.
This is my first black eye,
believe it or not.
I've never had a black eye before.
You know, uh.
Some people think they can just talk
to people any kind of way,
without any um,
any repercussions,
anything that's gonna happen to them.
But they're wrong because you can't talk
to everybody any kind of way
that you want to.
You have to give respect
in order to get it.
But some people don't see it that way.
They just want the respect
and to say, "Fuck how
you feel about anything."
Well, I got tired.
I got tired of accepting
bullshit from people,
not wanting to hear both sides of stories
and things like that.
And just,
whatever they say
that's what it's gonna be.
Whether they're right or wrong,
they're always right.
And this in particular person,
she's just evil.
Her heart fucking pumps oil.
She's blacked, just evil.
And I don't understand why.
You could be the nicest on earth,
come to her with common
courtesy and respect
and just be the most wonderful
person she's ever met.
And she'll still
cuss you out for something, whatever.
It would never make sense to me
or anybody else for that matter.
But it would always make sense to her.
When I first came down here,
it was the lifestyle
that was exciting to me.
Nobody just you will judge you
because everybody's doing something
and whether or not people know about it,
God knows what everybody's doing.
What's in the dark will come to light
and that's the truth.
Because I hid my addiction
as long as I could,
starting at 16.
16, I.
I started doing the more hard drugs.
You know, I tried, uh.
I started smoking sherm
when I was maybe 14.
I started using harder drugs,
16 years old.
That's when I made the worst decision
I could ever make in my life.
The first time I ever used crack cocaine.
The worst decision I could have ever made.
It's taken my family.
It's taken my jobs,
my car.
It's made me avoid all responsibility.
And it's because of this drug
I chose to distance myself
from all my family,
because I didn't want them to judge me.
And I didn't wanna see the
disappointment on their faces
because everybody had
such high hopes for me.
If I would've stayed
with my dad.
My dad tried so hard.
Not my father.
I have a father,
but he put me here on this earth.
I have a dad who's
always been there for me
since I was 11 years old.
Here I am now, 40 years old
and he's still there for me
as much as he can.
He don't approve of the lifestyle
that I'm living now,
which I do understand
because he tries so hard
to guide me in the right path.
And I still chose to go
to the streets.
I always felt like I had plenty of time.
I got plenty of time
to make up whatever I lost
or whatever it is that I need to do,
I always thought that
I had plenty of time.
All that time is gone now.
And it went by so fast.
Seemed like just yesterday
I was a teenager.
I was so happy to make it
to my 18th birthday
'cause I always thought I was gonna die.
Get killed in the streets
because I was gangbanging.
I was really gangbanging.
I was crippin.
I'm not gonna say where from,
but I was out there
and I did a lot of things to people.
I can finally say now,
I've humbled myself.
I don't know how else to put it.
I've become so humble
to where I accept people's bullshit.
Because I know if I go
back to my old self,
what's gonna happen to them.
It can also happen to me too.
The people out here don't realize that
the same person that
they take advantage of
and verbally abuse,
I'm that same person
that could take you off this earth.
I can get taken off this earth too.
But, I chose a different way.
I don't gangbang no more.
It takes a lot of shit.
I gotta.
I gotta be very angry
to start saying a cuzz
and all that other shit.
I grew out of gangbanging.
I grew up
on that level up here.
Gangbanging won't get you
nothing but life in prison
or six feet under.
There's no benefits in gangbanging.
But now one of my
daughters is gangbanging.
She just turned 21.
I can't tell her don't follow
her father's footsteps.
I tried but she won't listen.
The hood became her family
because I was never there.
I was never there
because I was too busy doing drugs
and living the life
that I wanted to live.
My biggest fear is that my daughter
is out there in the streets
and somebody rapes her
or she gets killed,
because she's from one
of the toughest hoods
that you could be from.
My daughter's from 60.
That's 60 Quilt, that's my daughter hood.
That's one of the most ruthless gangs
in Los Angeles.
And she loves that hood so much.
And I understand why,
because people will substitute
a gang as their family,
because they didn't feel the love
or they didn't have the support
that a family is supposed to give them
and their siblings,
or the daughters and sons.
She felt that connection
with the neighborhood.
So I can't be mad at her,
I'll be mad at myself,
because I chose the streets
and I chose my wants
and my needs over my own children.
Most of my kids are grown.
I have two younger boys.
They're both teenagers now.
I don't just,
even if I'm not in my kid's life,
I only want one thing,
for them not to do things that I did,
to not grow up the way that I did.
I want them to see things
that I've never seen before.
Expand their minds.
You know, listen to different music.
See that there's another world out there
other than the neighborhood
that you live in.
And that was one of my problems.
I was in the hood so long,
or I've always been afraid of change.
I didn't wanna go to another neighborhood
or go to a new school.
I wanted to stay within my comfort zone.
I've never been out of LA County, ever.
I've never been to Vegas, nothing.
I have,
I haven't seen anything
but what they show me on TV,
and in the books.
I haven't been anywhere
because I don't like change.
Change can be good
or it can be bad.
Sometimes change is for the better,
but then some sometimes change
can be for the worst too.
My changes was for the worst.
I've been to four different colleges.
I have a lot of smarts.
I have, I am educated.
I don't have it on paper though,
because I wanted to run the streets.
I could have been a number of things
as far as a career.
I can type 80 words a minute,
but you would never see that
or you wouldn't think so by looking at me.
I've had jobs
but I never kept them very long
because I was trying to
hang onto my street life,
and at the same time,
take care of my business
and my family.
I'm what they call a dysfunctional addict.
I can't run the streets and get high
and still take care of my business.
Something's got to give,
but you have um.
You have functional addicts.
People who've been getting
high, drinking for years,
and they still pay their bills on time,
take care of their family.
And the family will have no idea
that this person is
addicted to anything.
I'm not one of them.
I'm probably one of the
most dysfunctional addicts
that I know of
because I am my worst enemy.
I know that I'm gonna make bad decisions,
the wrong choices.
And I know this before I
actually made the choice
or the decision.
And I still end up doing the same shit.
Knowing that it's gonna be bad in the end,
I still go through with it,
because I want that,
that high.
I want to be free for the time being
because I have racing thoughts
that never stops.
I can never give my mind a break,
it's always running, racing.
My stress level is so high
because I know everything that I've lost.
The only thing I've gained from Downtown
is a bad arm
due to a spider bite.
This is a fucking spider
that did this to my arm,
from Downtown being on the streets.
And I let that infection sit
in my arm for three weeks
because I didn't wanna leave the streets.
When I got to the hospital,
they said if I would've
stayed outside one more day,
they would cut my arm off.
And I realized just how serious that was.
I thought that then,
I thought that it was just something
that was gonna pass.
I always let things heal on its own.
I never go to hospitals
or see the doctors.
Anything that happens to me,
like my eye, for instance,
I let it heal on its own.
You see my hand,
I broke my own hand
'cause I was mad at somebody,
and I punched a wall pretty hard in a gym.
My whole knuckle,
my hand is not the same anymore,
if you could tell the difference.
Because I chose to let it heal on its own.
Now my hand is permanently damaged.
I probably can't type 80
words a minute anymore,
but I can still type pretty good.
I can't do certain things
that I used to
due to this
skin graft that I have.
The spider laid eggs in my arm
and the infection
because I waited too long
to go to the hospital,
my arm got so big.
It was unbelievable.
They skinned my arm.
They took skin off of here,
whatever they cut off.
And then they skin grafted from my leg.
See.
Everybody thought that
I had been in a fire
because of the way my arm looks.
But this is for everybody Downtown.
This is a brown recluse spider
that did this to me.
So, for those who are out
there and not showering
and not taking care of
themselves as much as possible,
this can happen to you.
Whether it's on your face,
your ass, wherever,
you're gonna lose something.
I know I did
because I chose drugs over my own health.
I could have lost my right arm.
Then I'd have to learn
how to live with one arm.
And I'm not even left-handed
so that,
I don't know how hard it would be
to wipe my own ass with my left hand,
I've never done it.
You know, I'm right-handed.
Downtown has been the
downfall of my existence.
I have lost, just Downtown alone,
I have lost so much.
I lost all the trust from my family
just because of the addiction.
Not because of what I've not
or what I've done
or what I might have done,
but because they know
what addiction can do to a person,
especially the addiction that I have.
Anybody can make a change.
You're never too old,
and not too young.
If you can walk, talk,
and you're still breathing,
there's always a way.
Always.
But you have to want it
in order to get it.
You can't just talk about it,
you gotta put in work.
And it's not easy.
I know for me it's not.
I've quit doing drugs for,
different periods of time.
But then I always ended up
coming right back to it.
All it takes is one.
And that one hit,
that one shot,
whatever it is that you do
can ruin your life forever.
I have no idea where any
of my family members are.
I haven't seen my mother since 2011.
I don't know where she is.
My grandparents don't know where she is,
my uncles, nobody has a clue.
I don't know where any of my sisters are,
but my younger sister
that I grew up with from my mother,
she passed away in 2008.
I was in prison,
I didn't even get a chance
to say goodbye to her.
And the reason why I went to prison
is for having drugs.
My sister, she used to come down here
and beg me to come home.
And she would cry.
And I'd lie to her
and tell her I'm gonna be there soon.
And I would never show up.
Next thing I know I'm in prison
and my call home
they say your little sister died.
Then, I don't know.
I just wish I could
tell her how sorry I am
for the way I treated her.
I was a terrible big brother.
I was not even a big brother to her.
I always tried to push her away
and keep her away from me.
I have no idea why,
maybe it was jealousy
because her father was in her life
and mine wasn't.
Maybe that was the case,
I don't know.
But I wish I could take it all back.
My last thought of her
is her driving away in the car crying
because I wouldn't leave
with her to go home.
I felt all that guilt
when I got released,
and she passed away.
All the guilt of treating her bad
hit me all at once
like a ton of bricks.
And here I am after all these years
and she begged me to come home.
I'm still here.
And for what?
More worse stories?
At one point in time
when I was a teenager,
I was one of the best basketball players
in the county.
I was one of the best.
I mean, they were talking
like NBA type stuff,
but I didn't believe it.
You know.
Scouts would come in and look at us.
I was in a boys home,
as it's, when I was a teenager.
And people heard about
this team that we had,
we was good, we was great.
And I always ask myself,
what if I would've just
made the right decisions?
Could I be a retired NBA player by now?
Or whatever?
Could I have been anything
other than what I am today
if I would've made the right choice?
If I would've just listened to my dad.
My dad's name is Raymond Johnson.
Great man.
He's a great man.
He has a good heart.
He's the only man that's
ever been there for me
the way he has
and he's still there.
Even though I'm doing what I'm doing,
he just wants me to do better,
as everybody else wants me to do.
I want the same thing too,
but what is it gonna take for me to,
give up, to say I'm tired?
What is it gonna take?
I don't wanna lose a limb
or even worse, lose my life.
I don't want to be one of those
that dies down here
in some fucking tent
or on a sidewalk,
or while I'm sleeping,
a car jumps the curb
and ran me over.
It happens.
People die while they sleep,
getting ran over by a car
from an intoxicated driver
or something like that.
How the fuck does a car jump the curb
if you're sober?
That wouldn't make sense.
Something's wrong.
If you have an addiction,
or there's something out there
that you really like doing.
Whether it's alcohol, drugs, sex, food,
whatever it is,
don't get carried away with it.
Not even water.
If you're addicted water,
it can be bad for you.
I had to, I learnt that.
Too much water is bad.
What the fuck is that?
Too much of anything could be harmful
to the human body.
If you have a craving for something,
pray on it
and just
don't do it,
because you're gonna feel bad
once it's all over with.
Once you sold your belongings
and you're broke and no more drugs,
you're gonna feel bad
that you sold your shit to get high.
You're not even going to be high anymore
so you're really gonna be assed out.
Drugs can make you do things
that you never thought you would do.
I went to prison for strong arm robbery.
Um.
And I robbed somebody buying drugs.
I never thought I'd see,
see a day in prison in my life.
As I was growing up,
I might've been gangbanging
and doing whatever it is
that I might've been doing,
but I never saw myself going to prison,
'cause even though I was
living that street life,
I still kept myself,
I don't know, it's something about school,
even though I don't like school.
I do good in it when I put my,
when I,
when I go through with it.
When I, when I,
push through the effort to,
to make an accomplishment.
I haven't accomplished
many things in my life
other than what you see now.
The only accomplishment I've ever made was
making some beautiful kids.
That's the only thing I have.
So whenever I die,
there'll still be a part of me still here.
A piece of me will still be here on Earth.
Whether they, my kids know me, like me,
or love me.
And if they don't, I can understand,
and I'm okay with that.
I understand.
You know.
I'll still be here one way or the other
to my daughters, to my sons,
I'm still here.
I wish.
I wish that I never touched this stuff.
Drugs, I mean.
My mother,
I started out smoking weed
and she used to always say
that weed is a gateway to other things.
And I told her,
"You don't know what you're talking about.
I'm not gonna do any other drugs."
Even though I was
already doing other drugs
when she said that.
As much as I hate to say it,
my mother was right.
She was right.
She said, "Get you an education.
When you get older
you're gonna need it."
She was right.
I'm educated but I don't have it on paper.
I don't have a high school diploma.
Four different colleges,
I never got anything.
I never graduated
because sooner or later
I choose to go back
to the streets.
I...
I'm starting to get to the point where
I am starting to feel a little, I'm tired,
emotionally, mentally, physically,
but mostly mentally.
It's hard being out here,
especially when you let
people take advantage of you,
and use you,
and they take your kindness for weakness,
and your, and your,
your humbleness.
They take that shit for granted,
not knowing
who that person used to be,
or could be.
You never know.
They'll never know about me,
what I was,
because I refused to go back to that.
I don't like hurting people.
I have to be,
it takes a lot for me to get pissed off.
It takes a hell of a lot.
I mean, but after,
at some point, everybody has,
has a line that they draw.
They can't take no more.
So when I,
when you finally respond
to some of the bullshit
that people be throwing to you out here,
they feel some type of way,
because you're always the quiet one.
You're always not responding to anything.
Why the sudden change?
Because it's gotta change somehow.
At some point, no more disrespect.
You gotta give respect in order to get it.
Some people don't understand that.
They say common sense,
everybody has it.
And that's a lie.
It should just be called sense
'cause it's not very common,
'cause everybody don't have common sense.
Or maybe they do have it,
they just haven't tapped into that yet.
My eye is a result
of me standing up
for something that I believed.
I'll say it again.
You have to give respect
in order to get it.
It is not just one way.
This goes both ways.
You can't expect to talk shit to somebody
and expect for them to accept it
and be cool with it
without it eating them up inside.
That shit eats me up when I don't respond
and kick somebody's ass
or something like that.
Or just go back and forth
with the words with them.
If I don't
and I just let it happen,
it eats me up inside.
It just builds up
and I get mad at myself
because I didn't do or say anything
to that person.
But I do it anyway,
because I know what I'm capable of.
There's people out there
that I don't want to see me like this.
I want them to remember me for what I was.
You know, the good things,
I don't want them to see
this new person.
Like, "Who are you?"
I want them to remember me
as I was back then.
This person that they see now,
that they could see now,
they wouldn't know what to think.
I had it all
and I lost it all,
just like that.
All because of my bad decision-making.
Everything that happens to me down here,
I can't blame nobody but myself
because I chose to be down here.
The things that happened to me
might not be my fault,
but at the end of the day
it's all my fault
because I chose this over my family.
I chose this over my health.
"Let's get it together,"
I keep telling myself that every day.
And I feel the pressure of being tired
of the streets.
I'm starting to feel it now.
Before, all these years, it wasn't,
it wasn't on me like that,
but for some reason I feel different
about this shit now.
The streets are boring.
Everything's changed down here.
It's not fun no more.
It's bullshit.
We have people snitching on each other.
People hating on each other.
And just,
there's no love down here.
It's all lies.
Everything has a motive behind it.
Can't believe nobody, can't trust 'em.
So I don't get mad no more,
I get even.
I don't know why but
I just had the craving
to get even with people,
or should I say, get even with Downtown.
So, I stopped getting mad
and just started doing things to people
that they do to me.
And they don't like it
when I throw it back at them,
they don't like it.
I was that one person
that would always say, "Yes."
I don't like saying no to people.
I just, I don't know why.
I give people my last
or whatever it is that they asked me for,
if I can do it.
I'm sick of that
because at the end I'm
always the one that loses.
And.
I don't know, being
Downtown is very tiring.
You know.
It's draining.
If you, if you,
really think back on
all the shit that you,
that I've been through,
all the times I've been in jail.
I can't count how many
times I've been in jail.
I've been to jail more times than anybody
that I can possibly think of,
because of Downtown,
and my continuous use of drugs.
I had this...
I don't know.
It's time to get it together.
I'm stuck, man.
I don't know.
It's hard.
It gets real hard, man.
It gets hard,
but I can't be mad at nobody but myself,
because I chose this over my kids,
over my family, my grandparents,
I chose this over everything.
I have no connection
with nobody in my family.
I don't know where nobody is.
My dad is the only thing I got.
I love my dad so much,
because he never gave up on me.
Even though I'm living this life,
he's still there.
No, I'm not asking him
why he's giving me money all the time,
but he will help me when he feel it
that he needs to.
But if he thinks I'm just on some bullshit
and I'm asking him to
wire me money or whatever,
for my addiction or whatever,
he's not gonna help me.
And I do understand,
I understand completely,
the disappointment is so great.
I mean, I really had some
things going for myself
when I was younger.
Like I said before,
all it takes is one
and it could clean your whole life out.
Take away everything just like that.
I've seen people come down here,
brand new cars,
nice houses and shit.
And they come down here.
They started out as once or twice a week.
Then it'll come to be every day
they're coming down here.
Now they're in the same car,
but now it doesn't have that look anymore.
And now it's just, I don't know,
got a couple of dents
or maybe a rim is missing
and you're rolling on a donut wheel.
I've seen people deteriorate.
And what I mean by deteriorate,
I've seen them lose things step by step.
First is the house.
They're not paying their rent no more,
so they're sleeping in the car.
Then they end up losing the car
because they got too many tickets,
'cause they're in the same parking space
because they're sleeping in the car now.
The car is full of all their clothes
and belongings.
And guess what?
That's gonna get taken
because somebody is
gonna break their window
and take it all.
Now, these same people are
out here pushing baskets
and living on the street,
due to the same shit that I did,
because of bad decision-making.
This drug or these drugs
change your life forever.
They really can.
I've said this before
but if I can go back
in time and change it,
I would in a heartbeat.
I'd give my right arm,
any arm, I'd give whatever, a lung,
just to go back in time
and change my mistakes.
I want to be there for my kids.
I want to be a father.
I want to be a dad.
I'm a grandfather.
And my grandkids, they're young.
So, they're not old enough to understand
what it is that I'm going through.
But all my kids, they understand.
My kids are smart.
They're so smart
and they still love their daddy.
They love me.
And I'm so ashamed of what I've become
that I will not let them see me like this.
I refuse
to let my kids see me like this.
My older ones,
they see me a time or two
in this condition.
My daughter,
my 21 year old,
she came down here
and I didn't even know she was coming.
I hadn't seen her in
I don't know how long.
And she turned around,
she says, "Daddy."
And I turned around.
All I heard was that voice.
And I turned around and
it's my little girl,
my baby.
That's the one that's gangbanging now.
She loves her daddy so much.
God, man.
She loves her daddy.
She grew up so hard.
My daughter grew up
without her parents.
She didn't find out who her mother was
until she was grown.
She knew about me,
but I was in and out
because I wanted to live my life.
I was selfish.
I should have been there for her.
Maybe she wouldn't be where she is now.
I mean, as far as the gangbanging
and all the gang tats and stuff like that.
My daughter, she's fully with the business
in that hood shit.
She really is.
But I want her to change her ways.
My daughter has so much smarts
she can do hair.
She, she just,
she graduated high school
and I gave her thanks for that.
I like to feel like
I have something to do with that.
Because if I wouldn't have been,
if I would've been.
Who's to say that,
you know, I really do believe
that things happen for a reason.
Whether it's the smallest things
to biggest things.
Everything has a purpose.
Every second, every minute, every hour,
every movement,
everything that's going on around us
has a purpose for some reason.
And only God knows what it is.
Who's to say that
if I was there for my daughter,
that just assuming she
wouldn't graduate high school,
who knows?
And this might sound silly
but I feel like by me not
being there or whatever,
whatever purpose might be,
she graduated.
As weird as it sounds
I feel like I might,
my bad decisions, whatever,
however you want to call it.
I had something to do
with that in some way.
I don't know,
but I feel that.
But I won't even talk
about my daughter too much.
I hope that one day if she sees this,
baby, your daddy loves you very much.
And I'm so proud of you,
no matter what you decide to do
with your life.
You did something that
I was never able to do.
You graduated.
Good girl.
I miss you.
I love all my kids.
I love all of you.
Okay.
Uh.
Just say, "No."
Go the other way.
I know in life things happen.
Just try to make the best decisions
that you can for your future,
for your kids' future,
so you won't end up like me.
I love you.